this summer we're doing something quite
new and I think exciting Liz Lemon we're
going to be broadcasting a week of shows
from comic-con in San Diego yeah that's
right all of our comedy all of our
comedy and all of our guests are going
to relate to the magic of comic-con and
here's the important thing to know okay
- better coincide with all the events at
Comic Con we're going to be changing our
schedule a bit that week we're gonna be
airing our shows Wednesday through
Saturday July 8th through July 11th
we've never done anything like that
before it's pretty cool Wow yeah wait a
moment
are you saying that you'll be airing new
shows on Friday and Saturday yeah that's
right
but that's impossible you'll never air
new shows on Fridays and Saturdays I
know we've never done it before it's
pretty exciting well in that case I'd
better go set my DVR done anyway we
really are very excited to be
broadcasting from comic-con this summer
we're predicting a pretty amazing
response from some comic-con regulars in
fact let's see what Thor has to say
about it
[Applause]
he's not wrong - right he's right hey
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography